as you all know Ramadan is coming to us
soon Ramadan is a month of
forgiveness worship and a month from
which a person draws closer to his Lord
and it was narrated by the companions
that some of them they would supplicate
to Allah six months beforehand so that
they would reach the month of Ramadan by
saying Allah Ramadan Allah allow us to
reach the month of Ramadan and as you
all know Ramadan is a month of Good
Deeds charity prayer visiting the sick
all of these things are from the actions
of Iman and better ones Islam so let us
prepare for this blessed month and let
us not forget the mids appeal we need a
new place the community and the da is
growing and after Allah subhana T's
permission we are in need of your
efforts and your donations so let us not
forget the true investment the
investment of the afterlife and as you
all know the
narration whoever builds house for Allah
for his worship a mosque then Allah will
build for him a house in Paradise who's
to say this can't be our last Ramadan so
let us work hard collectively in trying
to establish a mid and we ask Allah to
accept our good deeds and allow us to
reach the month of
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramadan
continue our morning discussions and
this morning we will talk about starting
our day correctly so that we can enjoy
our day and so that it can be beneficial
for us and for others as well inshallah
tala and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he taught us in the sun
collected by iMed in his
and he declared it to be authentic he
taught us to say in the
mornings I've awoken upon the
Islam and upon the statement of
sincerity and upon the religion of our
Prophet
Muhammad and upon the religion of Our
Father ibraim who is he turned away from
sh and he worshiped
alone and he was not from the polytheist
he was a Muslim in this application
brothers and sisters we find so many
benefits in the morning imagine the
person they wake up they wake up Upon
A they
testify to a they Embrace a
acknowledging their purpose the reason
why they exist upon this Earth To
Worship Allah alone without any partners
and that they follow the son of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
just the fact that the individual
recognizes at the beginning of the day
the purpose why they exist in this world
is a path that leads to happiness and
these individuals by the will of Allah
they are those who go on to change
society they are those who are going to
benefit themselves and benefit others
because we cannot benefit others if we
do not benefit ourselves yes the Muslim
has a purpose as Allah said in the
Quran I did not create the Gin of
mankind except to worship me alone when
you know your purpose and you fulfill
your purpose you are a benefit to
yourself and you are benefit to others
in this world and if you die upon this
statement the statement that you wake up
in the morning testifying to the
statement
of you believe it in your heart you say
it with your tongue you act upon it with
your limbs and you depart from this
world upon you are guaranteed Paradise
so these are the people that will
prosper in this world and the these are
the people that will benefit in this
world and the that is why we should all
learn this supplication brothers and
sisters yes the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he taught us to
say have awoken upon the inate
disposition of Islam yes I love the
religion of Islam I love it I live by it
and I implement
it and upon the statement of
sincerity which is the key to paradise
and upon the religion of our Prophet
Muhammad sah Al wasam and upon the
religion of ibraim Our Father who was
Han a Muslim and he was not from the
polytheists yes look at the benefit
Subhan Allah that we find in this one
supplication so many
gems that is why yes Safety and Security
Allah guarantees for the people
of those individuals that actualize in
their lives Allah
said those who believe and they do not
mix with their belief shik oppression
referring to shik for them is security
and safety and they are guided yes the
supplication look at it analyze it we
wake up upon the of Islam upon the
statement upon the religion of our
Prophet Muhammad sahu alai wasallam now
you state it with your tongue you act
upon it with your limbs and something
cemented in the heart Allah subhana T
guarantees Safety and Security and
guidance for these individuals yes and
in the Hereafter they will be safe from
the punishment of Hell Allah
Grant